and with that we're proud to announce
the core cast of our upcoming Super
Smash Brothers feature film oh buddy I
can't wait to see who they cast as Mario
Chris Pratt will be playing Mario and
his voice will be unlike anything you
expect okay that's unexpected but uh
sure we'll go with it next to our
lovable yellow Pokemon Pikachu please
tell me they're bringing Ryan Reynolds
back it's The Unofficial sequel to
detective Pikachu Chris Pratt we wanted
a voice that truly matched what
audiences expect from this adorable
electric Mouse what joining the project
as the voice of The Intergalactic Bounty
Hunter Samus Aaron will be Zendaya Chris
Pratt isn't Chris on just the perfect
choice he's so cool oh come on and our
final announcement for the day will be
for the voice of Kirby as one of our
most beloved characters we wanted a
voice that lived up to all of your
expectations so voice and Kirby will be
uh let me guess Chris Pratt Idris Elba
after His Brilliant portrayal as
knuckles we couldn't imagine anyone else
in the role
you know what I'm okay with that
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that reminds you that if you
stop the Subscribe button long enough
you'll eventually get a one-up and no I
haven't made a mistake here this is not
the gaming channel believe it or not I
know multimedia Synergy can get
confusing welcome my friends to Mario
week here at theorist HQ we're going
live right now we have a companion video
over on our sister location Game Theory
talking about the brand new Nintendo
pictures movie studio yeah Casey missed
that news Nintendo bought itself a movie
company so step aside MCU it's time for
the rise of the ncu out with Doctor
Strange in with Dr Mario anyway I think
they're gonna be doing some wild stuff
with that one so go check out that video
by clicking the links that you see on
screen after you finish watching this
one meanwhile over here on film Theory
we're talking about another Nintendo
movie Project the upcoming Mario movie
you remember several months ago when
Shigeru Miyamoto crashed a Nintendo
Direct to announce the cast of an
upcoming Super Mario film made by
illumination entertainment creator of
the minions well if you don't remember
that maybe you do remember the giant
chorus of confusion that came as they
announced Chris Pratt as The Lovable
plumber Mario no
is Mario
yep instead of casting Mario's iconic
longtime voice actor Charles Martin a
for the part Universal gave the role to
Chris Pratt along with a number of other
celebrities like Jack Black as Bowser
and Seth Rogen as Donkey Kong the news
was so ridiculous that it spawned a meme
announcing that Chris Pratt would now be
voicing anyone and everyone in all
movies moving forward which lo and
behold suddenly manifested Pratt into
also voicing everyone's favorite
monday-hating cat Garfield in another
upcoming animated release yep that is
apparently gonna be a thing and we only
have ourselves to blame now listen
Hollywood stunt casting and animated
movies has been a thing for basically as
long as animated movies have been around
and whether or not this tactic actually
works to get more butts into theaters as
a theory for another day now what I'm
more interested in today is how silent
the project has been ever since that
Chris Pratt announcement I mean just
last week as I write this there was
another Nintendo Direct with Miyamoto
swooping in getting us all hyped for
Mario footage and then Pikmin 4 as far
as Mario news all we got was this the
Super Mario Brothers animated movie were
developing with Chris melodandre from
illumination who released next spring a
delayed next spring that's it Miyamoto
dipped and we're all still left
completely in the dark about this thing
well that was at least until right after
the Nintendo Direct where they announced
that they were going to be showcasing
the first teaser trailer for the film at
New York Comic Con it's about a week
from today but uh after being star for
Mario news for months I didn't want to
wait so I'm here to provide maybe not
news but gross speculation mildly
supported by evidence logic and critical
thinking so pretty much better than what
passes his news here in 2022 I want to
take another look back at the casting of
the Super Mario movie because I suspect
the choices the filmmakers have made
tell us a lot about their intentions
with this film and the type of story
they're planning to tell in fact I think
we can predict almost every major beat
of the plot for the entire movie Just
based on the casting alone and spoiler
alert friends if I'm right you might
just be looking at the video game
Industries version of Encanto right here
get those tick tocks at the ready so
before we get into the details we first
need to determine what sort of Mario
story The filmmakers are aiming to tell
see Mario games tend to fit into one of
two different silos there's the more
straightforward serious narratives where
there's a consistent internal logic and
a passable story think of games like
Super Mario 64 Sunshine Galaxy or
Odyssey princess gets abducted by space
Bowser we gotta save her Bowser wants a
wedding we gotta crash it princess make
cake Mario want cakes basic stuff but
there is a plot there on the other hand
you have some of the more meta games
stuff like Mario Kart party Sports you
know the games where Mario plays golf on
the weekends with the dragon Turtle who
kidnaps his girlfriend now the reflex
here might be to say that filmmakers are
gonna lean towards a less serious more
meta story because they've cast Chris
Pratt is the lead role after all he
played a similar lead character in The
Very meta Lego movie but I don't think
that this is gonna be the case for the
Mario movie not because of who's here
but rather because of who isn't here as
of yet there have been zero signs of the
metagame Mainstay characters like Daisy
Wario Bowser Jr Toadette or Internet
boyfriend Waluigi who alone would earn
the studio a ton of Free Press on
Twitter because he's the head of the
Nintendo meme machine no the main cast
of characters that Miyamoto announced
have all been fixtures of early core
Mario stories Toad Princess Peach Bowser
Luigi even OG arcade characters like
Cranky Kong and Donkey Kong but what
really clinches the origin story angle
for me is this announcement right here
casting someone for the role of Spike
now Spike has been the name of a couple
of Mario characters throughout the years
the most popular being a recurring enemy
that puke spiked balls out of his mouth
but despite they're referring to here is
actually very different notice the
little logo next to the casting
announcement a bearded man in a hard hat
this is actually a reference to a
character named Foreman spy if you've
never heard of him I don't blame you
he's so obscure and so old that I've
barely played his game you see form and
Spike comes from an obscure 80s NES
release called Wrecking Crew if you're
familiar with it at all it's probably
thanks to The Wrecking Crew stage in
Super Smash Brothers in the game you
have to knock down walls columns and
buildings all while being chased around
by masked eggplants I mean what do you
expect it was the early days of arcades
makes about as much sense as yellow
circle man avoids ghosts while consuming
fruit anyway the game is considered part
of Mario's origin story considering that
you play as Mario construction dude so
form and Spike probably wouldn't show up
in this movie unless it was trying to be
something similar which means I'm
leaning towards this Mario movie being a
genuine attempt to tell a Mario origin
story now don't worry I don't think this
is going to be a gritty realistic Zack
Snyder's Mario or anything like that but
come to think of it
foreign
origin story it lets us figure out that
the movie is almost certainly gonna
start in either New York City or the
video game equivalent new donk City
depending on how in Universe they want
to go with it again we can thank Foreman
spikes casting for that information
Foreman Spike was one of the antagonists
of wrecking crew where he was Mario and
Luigi's jerk boss as they worked
construction jobs around the city that
makes me believe that they're embracing
a lot of the early more grounded lore of
the franchise well as grounded as he can
be with giant Apes roaming around New
York either way this suggests that Mario
and Luigi are going to be from Brooklyn
or the new donk City equivalent complete
with gruffer New York accents rather
than the Whimsical Italian stereotype
that Charles martinet created for games
set in the Mushroom Kingdom the fact
that they're working for form and Spike
is also why I'm sure that Mario and
Luigi won't begin the movie as plumbers
now before you freak out I am very well
aware that all of this sounds a lot like
the awful live-action Super Mario
Brothers movie from 1993.
tall be proud go Goomba here's the thing
though all of this is actually in line
with early Mario franchise lore yeah
back when Mario was still named jump man
he was a carpenter because that made
more sense with the setting of those
games construction sites in cities they
didn't permanently switch him to plumber
until Mario Brothers in 1983 when the
setting of The Game suddenly shifted
down into the sewers of New York and
from there the role of plumber just kind
of stuck because Nintendo decided they
liked the pipe aesthetic for the first
Super Mario Brothers platformer but the
whole New York blue collar worker thing
yeah it's been a Mario series Mainstay
since the very beginning it's just
evolved and refocused itself a few times
over the years so like I said at the top
of the episode it's amazing what details
we can glean for the story just from the
cast list and we're just getting started
see I'm confident that the very first
conflict of the movie probably the
opening scene of the movie is gonna be
an adaptation of the original Donkey
Kong arcade game this is because Fred
Armisen has been cast as Cranky Kong
while Seth Rogen is playing a separate
Donkey Kong why would that matter well
the old curmudgeonly Cranky Kong that we
know from the Donkey Kong Country games
is canonically the same great ape from
the original arcade game the one that
kidnapped Pauline before throwing
barrels at Mario Jumpman Mario Donkey
Kong is cranky Kong's son so given that
cranky and Donkey are listed as two
separate characters and the fact that
the movie seems to be drawing from old
Mario lore likely that we're gonna see
those events from the original arcade
game play out in the film and because it
all happens at a construction site
wouldn't be surprised if it ends up
being the same one that Mario and Luigi
work at Under form and Spike Cranky's
inclusion also means that we're gonna
see a Time skip probably after that
opening scene see gorillas live
somewhere between 35 and 40 years on
average so for cranky to have kidnapped
Pauline and fought Mario in his prime
but then to be in an old man monkey in
the present day it's reasonable to
assume that something like 10 years have
passed also just because I feel like
this is the best place to call it out I
don't expect Mario or Luigi to be
wearing their iconic outfits at this
stage in the movie they might still have
overalls but I bet they'll be in
reversed or different colors reflecting
the original Sprites and concept art for
the characters having wildly different
color palettes the modern iconic look
for the Mario Brothers wasn't solidified
until the Super Mario Platformers so I'd
expect them gearing up into those for a
big final moment later on in the movie
so there you have it simple as that act
one of the film Cranky Kong kidnaps
someone at a construction site and a
young 15 to 20 year old Mario saves them
if they're keeping in line with Mario
Cannon the person kidnapped will be
Mario's first girlfriend Pauline as of
yet no one's been publicly announced to
play the character but that sort of
thing's common for minor roles and
animated films like this they'd announce
more minor cast members closer to
release to keep the movie in the
headlines so I wouldn't be surprised if
they have that announcement roll out
later that is unless they're planning on
mixing it up and Peach and Pauline
actually wind up being fused into the
same character which fun fact has been a
pet theory of mine for years that I've
never found the evidence to do see even
I have some evidentiary standards I mean
not much but it's good to know that
they're there somewhere anyway after
that opening rescue I suspect that we're
gonna see some sort of a Time skip
probably about 10 years or so to account
for cranky Kong's age again if we're
following Mario lore Pauline will either
be mayor of New York or New donk or be
campaigning for it after the time skip
just like the role that she plays in
Super Mario Odyssey at this point
traditional storytelling technique
demands that Mario want something during
this phase in the movie maybe he's
dissatisfied with his construction job
or with his life in general after seeing
people he knows like Pauline moving on
to bigger and better things maybe he's
upset with his antagonistic boss Spike
or he dreams of starting his own
business regardless of what it is Mario
is dissatisfied with where he is in his
life and this want is gonna be the thing
that gets the adventure started given
that the plumbing aesthetic of the Mario
franchise started specifically in the
sewers of New York something is gonna
draw Mario and Luigi down there I
believe this this is where Seth Rogen's
Donkey Kong is gonna enter the picture
setting a trap for the Mario Brothers I
say this because Rogan is billed as one
of the top six actors for the film and
given that we've already established DK
exists in the New York section of the
world rather than the Mushroom Kingdom
section we gotta find a way to get him
into the rest of the story Somehow Here
Mario and Luigi will fight Donkey Kong
at the end of Act One probably with a
bunch of turtles and crabs crawling out
of pipes like we see in the Mario
Brothers game finally like any good
anime the triple somehow be izakide into
the Mushroom Kingdom through a magic
pipe so we can finally hop on over to
the Mushroom Kingdom and meet the rest
of the cast starting in act 2. here in
Act 2 I expect the movie is gonna draw a
lot from the early Mario franchise games
specifically it's gonna be more or less
an adaptation of the original Super
Mario Brothers for the NES you know the
classic stuff Bowser invading the
Mushroom Kingdom kidnapping Princess
Peach after Mario and Luigi arrive
sending the brothers on their journey to
stop King Koopa this will set up two
important points for our narrative here
first seeing Peach get kidnapped like
Pauline is gonna remind Mario of the
heroic man that he used to be in his
younger year encouraging him to try and
recapture some of his earlier spark it's
also here that we're gonna see Donkey
Kong switch's loyalties going from an
antagonist to more of a comedic support
for Mario and Luigi I say this primarily
because of Seth Rogen's casting and
these sorts of family-friendly animated
films Rogan tends to be the comedic Ally
for the main good guy think of his Parts
as Pumbaa in The Lion King or Bob in
Monsters vs Aliens combine that with
reports of a Donkey Kong spin-off in
development that means that DK is gonna
need to steal a fair bit of screen time
to set that film up now this is a pretty
wild shot in the dark but if I had to
guess I'd say that seeing how the
kidnapping of Princess Peach devastates
the kingdom of toads will make Donkey
Kong realize that cranky was wrong all
those years ago about kidnapping people
or maybe Bowser just stole a big old
horde of DK's bananas and that just made
him hangry either way DK is probably
gonna join the good guy side here also
Princess Peach will not be the helpless
Damsel in Distress that she is in the
classic Mario Platformers mostly because
that would be tone death this is 2022
after all that sort of stuff doesn't fly
anymore plus Anya Taylor Joy is a girl
boss she has a ton of serious projects
playing powerful women under her belt I
doubt she'd want her only lines here to
be help me Mario and here's your cake
Mario so I expect Peach to take an
active role in her own rescue from here
expect the story to play out like a
classic Super Mario game Mario Luigi and
Donkey Kong Adventure through the
mushroom Kingdom's various biomes going
from Castle to castle looking for peach
and would be surprised to see a funny
Montage of Mario freeing a castle only
for toad to say the princess is in
another Castle meanwhile over in his
Fortress Bowser and Peach will share a
lot of scenes together where she's
trying to escape as he attempts to woo
her like it's a romantic comedy for the
final battle Mario and Luigi get their
iconic overalls just so we can make sure
that there are some money shots for the
trailer and also a bunch of new merch
for Nintendo Land and Universal Studios
true to the first game Bowser will
probably meet his end on a bridge likely
falling into lava but don't worry this
won't be the last that we see of King
Koopa the post credits will reveal him
nursing his wounds the camera will pan
out for the big teaser reveal of the
Koopalings I mean it could be Bowser Jr
but let's face it the Koopalings are way
more synonymous with early Mario games
and would get way more hype in the press
and that's it Mario's Arc will be
resolved his dissatisfaction with life
will disappear as he finds new purpose
in the Mushroom Kingdom cue a final
Easter egg joke of Donkey Kong Mario and
Luigi hopping into go-karts and racing
off into the sunset as the scream Fades
to Black so that's how I see the story
of this Super Mario movie playing out
but don't click away to my other Mario
theory on Game Theory just yet my
friends we're not done here see loyal
theorists there's a last cherry on top
of this plot prediction that I think is
going to convince you that I'm
omniscient if I get right my wild swing
for the fences Theory here is that this
Super Mario movie is gonna be a musical
why do I say that first of all
illumination entertainment has itself a
history of making movies where gorillas
break out into songs in fact a shocking
number of their films or musicals
including ones that are even based on
non-musical Source materials
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
this movie is going to be a musical but
I also ask you to once again look at the
cast list literally all of them have
histories with music in some way or
another let's just do a quick roll call
here Chris Pratt has a surprisingly
decent singing voice and he's already
started an animated movie musicals like
the aforementioned Lego Movie likewise
Charlie Day basically takes every
opportunity he has to add singing into
its Always Sunny in Philadelphia Keegan
Michael Key's biggest secret weapon
might be his singing voice
love in all the same old places even
actors with smaller announced roles here
like Kevin Michael Richardson and Fred
Armisen have pipes the weakest singing
voice of everyone who's been cast so far
would be Seth Rogen and even he's still
sung in movies like The Lion King remake
but the biggest casting coup for
illumination here has to be Anya Taylor
joy and Jack Black because their Bowser
and Peach they are guaranteed to share a
lot of scenes and therefore at least one
musical number Anya Taylor Joy has a
history as a studio recording artist and
has an amazing voice
Jack Black on the other hand is a master
comedic musician in his own right being
half of the metal band Tenacious D and
being well known for his roles in films
like The Pick of Destiny and school of
rock this pair sharing a musical number
together is almost too good to pass up
just imagine Bowser whipping out a
guitar and trying to woo Princess Peach
through song and dance it writes itself
and thing people are surprised by the
Chris Pratt announcement wait till they
hear Mario burst out in the song in the
first trailer so there you have it my
friends feel free to sit the next
Nintendo Direct out miyamoto-san I've
got you covered the Mario movie is Gonna
Be An Origin story starting with
construction sites and Kongs and ending
with Bowser and ballads and hey since I
saved you the time please go back to
working on Mario Odyssey 2 it's been too
long without a main series Mario title
but hey that's just a theory a film
Theory and now's your chance dear viewer
to go check out our other new video on
Game Theory talking about the brand
spanking new Nintendo pictures movie
studio trust me I think Nintendo is
getting up to some weird shenanigans
that no other movie studio could get
away with but to find out exactly what I
mean you have to click on over to that
video right now right now link is on
screen not gonna say it again you're
smart go watch it